>> Rob Casper: Welcome.
Good morning.
Welcome to the National
Book Festival.
My name is Rob Casper.
I'm the head of the Poetry and
Literature Center at the Library
of Congress and we're
thrilled to have you
for this panel celebrating
new poets of Native Nations.
I should say it's both
a panel and a reading,
so you'll hear all
sorts of poems
in the next hour and 15 minutes.
We'll have a great wonderful
conversation up on stage,
and you'll have the
opportunity to ask questions.
There should be mics on either
side that you can step up to.
When we get to that
point I'll redirect you
so we can make sure that works.
All day here at the Library
of Congress National Book
Festival we are recognizing
and celebrating the
importance of reading
and authors and books.
The Library of Congress makes it
seem easy to do this every year,
but the truth is the National
Book Festival is a huge
undertaking, is a huge financial
undertaking, and it is free
for everyone because
of the generous support
from our sponsors
and supporters.
One of our great sponsors
and supporters is the
National Endowment for the Arts
which makes this poetry and
prose pavilion possible.
You should find out about the
National Endowment for the Arts.
The staff from the Literature
Division is in the back.
They have materials
you can check out.
They are a great supporter
of poets and writers
in this country and have been
doing so for a good long time.
You can also spread the joy
of reading with a gift online
at loc.gov/donate
from the festival app
or when you purchase
books today.
So let me tell you about
this panel in reading.
We have a good amount
of time today to get
into a great conversation.
And I'm thrilled to have two
wonderful poets including my
good friend Heid Erdrich.
I've had many conversations
with Heid over the years
about new poets of
Native Nations and I want
to say how honored
I am personally
to be part of its launch.
Special thanks also to Graywolf
Press and Editor Jeff Shotts
for supporting this panel.
We were supposed to
have a third panelist
and reader, Natalie Diaz.
She is in transit.
We're hoping she makes it, so
we're just going to kick off
and then we'll see what happens.
Let me tell you a little
bit about this event.
Our other poet, Jennifer
Foerster, will read her poems
from the anthology, then
Heid will talk a little bit
about the anthology and read
poems by other contributors.
Then she'll invite Jennifer to
ready selections from new poets
of Native Nations as well,
and I'll lead a moderated
discussion.
Let me say a little
bit about the Poetry
and Literary Center as well.
We are home to the U.S.
Poet Laureate, and in fact,
you can see our current Poet
Laureate, Tracy K. Smith,
talk with former Poet
Laureate, Robert Hass,
at this stage at 2 o'clock.
The Center also hosts a wealth
of poetry programming
throughout the year
at the Library's Capitol Hill
Campus and around the country.
For more information,
visit loc.gov/poetry.
And so now I'm going
to sit down,
and there will be a little
bit of rejiggering my mic,
and then Jennifer Foerster
will kick things off.
So, thanks for much for coming.
>> Jennifer Elise
Foerster: Sorry, I --
oh, right there [laughter].
Hello. [Foreign words].
Jennifer Foerster
[foreign words].
My name is Jennifer Foerster.
It's wonderful to be here.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
It's good to see all of you.
I'm a member of the Muscogee
Creek Nation through my mother,
and I'll say a few things more
in Muscogee just to
introduce myself.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
So it's wonderful to be here.
I just mentioned my
clan through my --
I'm a daughter of
the Beaver Clan.
And it's been such
an honor to be apart
of this incredible anthology
that Heid Erdrich put together.
I think it must have taken a lot
of work to put this together.
I know it did.
And I admire her so much for
her incredible contributions
over the years and all
the work that she's done
for Native literature.
Truly bringing Native
writers to the landscape,
the literary landscape,
which is so important
because we've always been a
part of the literary landscape.
We just haven't been
included in it.
But so much of the literature
of this country and the idea
of the country is --
involves all of the peoples
of this country and our stories.
So this is a great contribution,
and I'll read a few poems
of mine from this anthology.
All right.
There we go.
So my mother us Muscogee Creek,
and our family is from Tulsa,
and one of the early
founding families of Tulsa.
And arrived there during the
removal in the mid-1800s.
And my father is Dutch and
German and was in the Air Force,
so I grew up moving
around a lot as a kid.
So I only got to spend
summers back home in Oklahoma,
and the rest of the time -- he
was a diplomat in the Air Force
so he worked in the -- for
the embassies and we lived
in Vienna, Austria,
and Brussels,
England, and various states.
So, you know, because we
worked for the government,
they were kind enough to send us
home every summer, and so I got
to go home to Oklahoma
every summer.
I always felt a little out of
place because it was my home and
yet we were the ones that were
always moving around, you know.
And not a lot of people
there moved around.
So I felt like I
was always leaving.
So the first book I titled,
Leaving Tulsa because
I always wanted to stay,
but I also always
wanted to leave.
And it's that place of
being in-between culturally,
linguistically, historically,
that informs this poem.
"Leaving Tulsa."
Once there were coyotes,
cardinals in the cedar.
You could cure amnesia with
the trees of the back-forty.
Once I drowned in
a monsoon of frogs.
Grandma said it was
a good thing,
a promise for a good crop.
Grandma's perfect tomatoes.
Squash. She taught us
to shuck corn, laughing,
never spoke about her
childhood or the faces
in gingerbread tins
stacked in the closet.
She was covered in a
quilt, the Creek way.
But I don't know this kind
of burial -- vanishing toads,
thinning pecan groves,
peach trees choked by palms.
New neighbors tossing clipped
grass over our fence line,
griping to the city of
our overgrown fields.
Grandma fell in love with a
truck driver, grew watermelons
by the pond on our
Indian allotment,
took us fishing for dragonflies.
When the bulldozers came with
their documents from the city
and a truckload of pipelines,
her shotgun was already loaded.
Under the bent chestnut,
the well where Cosetta's
husband hid his whiskey --
buried beneath the roots
her bundle of beads.
They tell the story
of our family.
Cosetta's land flattened
to a parking lot.
Grandma potted a cedar sapling I
could take on the road for luck.
She used the bark for
heart lesions doctors
couldn't explain.
To her they were maps, traces
of home, the Milky Way,
where she's going, she said.
After the funeral I stowed
her jewelry in the ground,
promised to return
when the rivers rose.
On the grassy plain behind
the house one buffalo remains.
Along the highway's gravel pits
sunflowers stand in dense rows.
Telephone poles crook
into the layered sky.
A crow's beak broken
by a windmill's blade.
It is then I understand
my grandmother --
when they see open land
they only know to take it.
I understand how to walk
among hay bales looking
for turtle shells.
How to sing over the groan
of the county road
widening to four lanes.
I understand how to
keep from looking up --
small planes trail
overhead as I kneel
in the Johnson grass
combing away footprints.
Up here, parallel to the median
with a vista of mesas' weavings,
the sky a belt of blue and white
beadwork, I see our hundred
and sixty acres stamped
on God's forsaken country,
a roof blown off a shed,
beams bent like matchsticks,
a drove of white cows
making their home
in a derailed train car.
[ Applause ]
"Canyon. I also lived for a
long time in New Mexico and went
to the Institute of American
Indian Arts in Santa Fe.
And now I'm there with a
low residency MFA Program
at that school.
And some of the poets in
the anthology are involved
with that school, too.
So keep your eye out.
"Canyon." So, anyway, so I spent
a lot of time in the desert
which has influenced me a
lot, especially the Southwest
and the sense of the ocean that
is always there in the desert.
The past is always a
part of where we're at,
even if we don't see it,
even when it's invisible
in our landscape.
It's here.
"Canyon." Brush over stars
dust, up thrust shale,
erosion stripped
script of leaches.
Sloughing scales off our
hands' finned imprints.
Slow, ageing metamorphic
skins, quartz, schist, gypsum,
marine bones bedded
in the drainage.
The basin overflows with
wind, horizon, phantom barges,
a shore once lush with cane.
Moon, a relic in the azure sky.
Grey face cut from
the mountain spine.
A line of dust divides
us, [inaudible] and ghost,
ancient stream whose sound
remains, flood land, arroyo,
yucca, sowoaro [assumed
spelling].
I dive with pipe
fine swallowtails
down winding stairs, crenulated
lava, scrolls fossilized
in radiant strata,
reed, prickly pear,
silver cholla, spicules
of sponge.
Here in this rain shadow's
stark flanked gully,
two blue-bellied lizards
streak across sand,
vanish inside a conch
shell, arrived at the bottom
of the world, I write.
Buried in the canyon's
spiraled larynx,
a raft for the coming storm.
[ Applause ]
Want me to go on?
Okay. I'll read one piece
from my second book
that just came out.
That kind of follows --
that poem is in this book,
but it's called Bright
Raft in the Afterweather ,
so since I'm talking
about rafts.
This is called "Hookdalwe's
[assumed spelling] Crow."
Hookdalwe is a Muscogee
word for an elderly woman.
It doesn't have the personal
pronoun attached to it
so it can't be a relative
because a relative always
has that attachment.
So it' an elderly
woman who has --
it's kind of close
to a grandmother.
And she informs this book.
She's kind of the character.
The first book is following a
woman named Magdalena and she is
like the chimera of the book.
And so this one is --
takes place at the edge of
the continent in California
where I've moved to
and where I now live.
And it's following this
elderly woman named Hookdalwe
who I've seen various places
on the beach and around.
So she's who I write to.
Hookdalwe's Crow.
There were still songbirds than
nesting in hackberry trees.
And a butterfly named Question.
I remember ivy trembling at the
vanishing point of your throat.
Then the timelines crashed.
California split
into an archipelago,
orchards withered
under blooms of ash.
Now there is no nectar,
no rotten fruit.
The air is quiet.
Once in Russia, ornithologists
trapped a population
of hooded crows, transported
them 500 miles westward.
Winter came.
They never caught
up with their flock.
With crests of calcified algae
we catalog each day lost.
Hot thermals, cirrus vaults,
fistfuls of warblers
hurtling into dark.
There was no sound
to the forgetting.
We knew the heart would
implode before the breath
and lungs collapsed.
That the world would
end in snow.
An old woman walking alone,
empty birdcage strapped
to her back.
[ Applause ]
>> Rob Casper: That's
a beautiful poem.
>> Heid E. Erdrich:
Thank you so much.
Am I on? Is my mic working?
Yeah?
>> Jennifer Elise
Foerster: Yeah.
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Okay.
Thank you so much,
everybody, for being here.
Thank you, Jennifer.
That was just beautiful.
I am Heid Erdrich and I wanted
to say just a few more things
about Jennifer before
we move on.
Jennifer has recently
been a National Endowment
for the Arts Fellow.
She is working as
Managing Editor
of Joy Hardrow's
[assumed spelling] project
to create a Norton
Anthology of Poetry
of Native American
Poetry , the first.
[ Applause ]
And if that's not enough,
she recently stepped
in as the Director of the MFA
Program, the Low-Res MFA Program
for the Institute of
American Indian Art,
so she's quite an
accomplished person aside
from having a new book out,
which is enough work as it is.
And so I'm really grateful to
you for coming in and reading
from The Anthology .
I really appreciate that, so.
>> Rob Casper: Do you
want to read a few poems
from The Anthology
that you love?
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Yeah.
I'm going to read the first and
last and then as we have time
between things I will add
a few of the shorter poems.
I'd like to read the first
poem because, you know,
we have a book where I
created this umbrella,
Native American Poetry,
and I don't believe
that Native American
Poetry actually is a thing.
It's just a term that we use
to bring the original peoples
of this place together.
And when I move around the
country reading from my own work
and The Anthology and
teaching, I like to think
about the original people
who lived in the place
that we're all inhabiting,
so I want to think
about those people now.
I want to recognize them
in OccuNations of Virginia
who recently came
into a relationship
with the Federal
Government after, of course,
having known people from
Europe for hundreds of years.
So I want to recognize
those people.
And then I want to read --
[ Applause ]
Thank you.
Then I want to read the first
poem in the book which is
by Tacey M. Atsitty ,
and Tacey's a Dine poet.
She also a graduate
of the Institute
of American Indian Arts
with an MFA from elsewhere.
But she did her undergraduate
work there.
Tacey is writing about the
ancestral group that is known
as the Anastasi [assumed
spelling], you know,
that's sort of a made-up
term for people's ancestors.
And the conventional wisdom is
that they just disappeared,
right?
This group in the
Southwest, the Hohokam,
the Anastasi, all these people.
Nobody knows where they went.
Well, the people
who are descended
of them know where they went.
So this is a very short poem.
"Anastasi."
How can we die when
we've already been prone
to leaving the table
mid-meal like ancient ones,
gone to breathe elsewhere?
Salt sits still, but pepper's
gone, rolled off in a rush.
We've practiced dying
for so long a time.
When we skip-dance or
town, when we chew.
We've rounded out like dining
room walls in a canyon,
eaten through by wind.
Sorry we rushed off.
The food wasn't ours.
Sorry, the grease sits
white on our plates.
And the jam that didn't set.
Use it as syrup to cover
every theory of us.
[ Applause ]
So that was Tacey M. Atsitty
who gave me permission
to read that poem.
When I put The Anthology
together I wasn't sure how I
was going to do it.
I knew I wasn't going to look
for themes because I believe
that all these representatives
of their own Native Nations,
their particular culture
groups or their relationship
to their descent from
those culture groups
which is a whole other
category of being,
were too distinct to represent.
I couldn't, you know,
put it in a category
of here's Creek poets
or here's Dine poets.
What I wanted was a sense
of when these writers entered
the American mainstream
of poetry by publishing
their first books.
So when I read that poem of
Tacey's, I realized I wanted it
to be the first poem in the
book, and because it responds to
and calls out our ancestry,
our origin in this
place, this continent.
And because it was the
last book published.
And I realized I had to go
backward from the 2018 book,
Tacey's book, Rain Scald ,
and forward to the first book
published in the year 2000
to have 21 poets from
the 21st century.
So the last poem in the book
which I had always wanted
to be the last poem in the book
is from Janet McAdams who's
of Creek descent from Alabama.
And this poem is
called "Earthling."
That winter, that warm winter,
no one wanted to be ordinary.
We sat on a pile of
plastic, threatened as a farm
where the dog is
tied up barking.
Land, we meant to
say we were sorry.
We are so sorry to the
red dirt of your body.
We meant to say meat
or dirty water.
We meant to say before our
bones became lace, before we had
to lean forward to swallow.
You remember how the story goes.
We came in peace.
But tell that to a drop
of water trying to linger.
[ Applause ]
So those are the
first and last poems.
And I think in my conversation
with Rob, I'll get to some
of the other things
I want to tell you
about The Anthology , so.
>> Rob Casper: Well, thanks
for reading those
poems, both of you.
And talking about timelines,
I felt it appropriate to start
with a timeline for this
anthology which is the timeline
of 20 years ago, the
last major Anthology
of Native Poetry and the
forthcoming Norton Anthology
Mwhich I just learned about
which I'm assuming is coming
in the next few years.
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Mm-hmm.
>> Rob Casper: And here between
the future of the "Nortonizing"
of Native poetry and
this last anthology
that people could refer to
when they wanted to find
out who are the exciting Native
poets writing great work today
sits new New Poets
of Native Nations ,
and I think it's a
really interesting title.
And I wanted to talk to you
about what this title means,
especially in relation
to the sort of past
and the imminent future.
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Mm-hmm.
Well, you know, I'll
tell you how I --
the poetry anthology came to be.
I was looking at social
media, as I'm want to do,
and I saw a prominent
critic of American Poetry,
Contemporary American
Poetry, post the question,
who are the Native Poets
I should be reading today?
And the answer this person
got back were the names
of 19-century orators like
Chief Seattle, Gary Snyder,
who is not Native but who can --
some people think of as
writing Native American Poetry.
The names of, you know,
well-known and established poets
like Joy Harjo, and then
the names of several people
who are not Native but use names
that sound Native in English.
And that really concerned me.
It took many comments before
Layli Long Soldier's name came
up, before some of the
poets who published books
in the past three years, Sharon
Bitsoi [assumed spelling]
who did the cover image
for this anthology.
And I would love to talk about
that image if I get a chance.
And, you know, the folks
we wanted in there.
I don't think I commented.
I just sat back and
thought about that.
And I had the gall to write
to Jeff Shotts and go, Jeff,
there has not been an
anthology of Native Poetry
from a literary press.
There have been anthologies
of indigenous poetry
from university presses that
cover the whole landscape,
the whole continent, North
and South America
and Central America.
But there hadn't
been a literary book
about whose poets were
publishing books today,
and there was nothing that
wasn't themed or set together
in what I feel is sort of
an artificial apparatus.
So I sent this audacious note
to Jeff Shoots at Graywolf
and he kindly said
that's a great idea.
Let's talk about it.
And then I got scared and
I started like who am I?
Do I know all the poets?
You know, who do I know?
And I made a list of 43 poets
that I thought would be good
for this anthology, and
then I started to research
who was coming next and
added to the gaps that I had.
I didn't realize
how many gaps I had.
One gap I had that became
apparent very early on was
that there is a division
between the literatures
of academic writers, writers
who wrote for university presses
or Native series, and
writers who wrote perhaps
to their audience whether
it be gender or class, race,
issues that had more of an
audience in specific niches.
So I ended up really looking
beyond what was comfortable
for me and creating, I
think, a pretty eclectic book
but that holds together in ways
that are apparent to me, so.
>> Rob Casper: Jennifer,
I wonder if you could talk
about what you see this
anthology as doing in relation
to the anthology you're
charged with helping edit.
>> Jennifer Elise
Foerster: Well, first of all,
I love the title
of this anthology
because that's really
what it's doing --
to state new poets of Native
Nations is a first step
in changing the way that
the literary world responds
to literature by people
of Native Nations,
is I feel like there has
been, you know, this --
part of the response to
literature by people who are
of Native Nations is
to lump them into --
oh, my gosh, first of
all, there are more --
there are many Nations
inside this Nation.
Yeah. There's a lot.
And people write, yeah.
And people from the many Nations
inside this Nation have not only
been telling stories, which is
literature, and singing songs,
which is literature forever,
but have also been writing.
And that's often
not thought about.
But, actually, we have
written literatures from people
of many different
Nations since, I'd say --
I mean, it depends also if
you're thinking of what kind
of written -- about 1600's.
So there's an amazing history
and heritage of literatures
of people from the many
Nations with this Nation,
the Indigenous Nations.
And it's time that
it gets recognized.
That's part of the story.
If we're going to tell a story,
what is our national literature?
What is the story
of assassinations?
And, you know, when that first
started coming to be, you know,
late 1800s, so we need
a national literature,
and Whitman and, you
know, this kind of --
wow, the country
is being identified
by a national literature.
In-between World War I and
World War II there was that --
we need to have an identity
as a people with a literature.
Those writers were held up.
And not that that
wasn't important,
but those people became
the literary ones.
And meanwhile there
are so many others.
And it's just time that we
start responding to that.
And that will change the
stereotypical narrative
of who we are as a nation
in relation to, you know --
there's always this
we as a nation
and then there is the
Natives, you know?
Like us, we, them, one other.
And, in fact, it's we
are multiple nations
with different languages
and different customs
and different stories.
So this book -- that's what I
love [inaudible] I love so much
about it, but what I would
just say what's captured
in the title, New Poets
of Native Nations .
It's such an important change.
>> Heid E. Erdrich: That makes
me think I didn't really answer
the question about
the title [laughter].
>> Jennifer Elise Foerster: Oh.
>> Rob Casper: We had time to
have that question answered.
But I did want to follow up
and say what struck me most,
especially when you consider
the sort of Norton Anthology
of Poetry model, is that it
began with new and new poets
that have foregrounded
that this anthology --
I shouldn't speak of
it in the past tense.
This anthology foregrounds
the writers of these poems
and pronounces them as new
in a really beautiful
and wonderful way.
And maybe you could
talk about that.
>> Heid E. Erdrich:
Yeah, thanks.
I mean, you know,
it's 18 years ago
that the first book
was published,
but there were very few
Native poets published,
especially by literary presses,
and I make that distinction
because there's a
different audience.
You're more likely to see
a book of poems published
by a literary press as opposed
to a university press just
on a shelf somewhere
in a bookstore.
And so there were just,
there were just a very few
until the beginning
of this century.
There was just a moment, a
divide, after the late '90s
where people started
to publish in numbers,
and some presses would have not
just one Native poet, but two.
And I say in the
Introduction that I --
when my second collection of
books, I was actually told
by some of the presses, well,
we already have a Native poet
so we can't consider your work.
Somebody not from my Nation,
not from my perspective,
and so forth.
But there was that
lumping together.
So I really wanted the
idea to like look at, well,
you couldn't -- it's
enough to represent
in some way your nation or
hold that nation in your body
and have it be part of
your work for these poets,
much less to try to fit into
some category of thematic,
you know, work by
Native Nations.
So I think -- I mean, I really
was thinking about those things.
I was also thinking about that
problem of these poser poets,
[inaudible], pretend
Indians as we call them,
people who have made
a career off
of writing Native-sounding
poetry but have no connection
to a Native Nation whatsoever.
And they don't even
pretend to when asked.
But that is -- you know, I
really wanted people to begin
to see a difference, so the
craving for a 19th century voice
that has a particular sound was
put to rest as being something
that maybe Longfellow did
after he ripped off James
Rhonson's [inaudible],
the first Native poet who
published in 1824, so.
>> Rob Casper: I'm interested
also in talking specifically
about these poems and
the wealth of themes
and images these poems contain,
and the images and themes
that how you talk about in
the Introduction as those
that the publishing world,
the sort of mainstream
publishing world expects
of Native poets.
Reading through this
anthology, what should I
and everyone here come to
expect about the latter?
What should be understand
about these sort of themes
and images we've been
told or been reinforced
from the publishing world
that are Native themes,
Native images?
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Well,
that's always a problem, right,
like if I recapitulate them then
they're in your head because --
and then I tell you but I
can't tell you what, you know,
what subject will strike Native
contemporary, new Native poets.
But, you know, the
expectation of spirituality,
constant spirituality, you know.
We have poems for --
anti-spiritual poems.
We have, you know, agnostic,
even atheistic poems
in this anthology.
You know, animals
aren't always talking.
People aren't always
in ceremony.
They might write, you know,
beautifully about canyons
and the relationship
to ancestors,
but with the sensibility
that we have as Americans,
to be skeptical to
think, you know,
how is our education
being produced,
what's our critical take?
So those are the poets
I was attracted to.
There are many other kinds of
Native poets, and I did try
to include some in the edition
of Poetry Magazine
that I edited for June.
So that's online.
So if you want to see some
poets who are not contained
in this anthology, you can
see in Poetry Magazine ,
even newer writers who have --
maybe don't have
their first book yet.
But these writers, like Jennifer
said, are national poets
in the American scene
in general.
They've won virtually every
major award this year.
Jake Skeets, who's
not in the anthology,
just won the National
Book Award?
No. The National Poetry Series.
>> Jennifer Elise
Foerster: Yeah, yeah.
The Poetry Series.
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Yeah.
>> Jennifer Elise Foerster:
I know that [inaudible]
to me, but that's awesome.
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Yeah.
And, you know, every
-- if you ask about it,
there have been awards --
Joshua Whitehead actually turned
down the Lambda Literary
Award, but he was nominated.
And there were many other
awards just recently that went
to Native poets, not
in a special category,
just the American
Poetry Awards in general.
>> Rob Casper: Well, there's
also that interesting sense
of multiple identities that you
talk about, the essence of --
our connection to different
Nations that the poets
of this anthology
are negotiating with.
At one point you say that no one
in this anthology
defines himself solely
as Native American.
Can you back that up a
little bit, Jennifer?
Maybe I -- maybe you could talk
about how your work and the work
of the poets that you admire in
this, negotiate with those dual
or multiple identities maybe
in connection with one another
or in opposition to one another.
>> Jennifer Elise Foerster: Hmm.
I have a sense -- I feel lucky
that I am friends with most
of the poets in here,
and those are not --
it's just because I haven't
had the privilege of getting
to know them very well yet.
But one thing about
this collection
that Heid has brought
together is that as --
this collection of poets,
including so many who aren't
in here, we're in
conversation often.
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Mm-hmm.
>> Jennifer Elise
Foerster: We know each other.
We dialog.
We read each other.
We teach each other.
So in that sense it's a small --
well, it's an intimate
community.
>> Heid E. Erdrich:
Mm-hmm, I agree.
>> Jennifer Elise Foerster: And
this is just a beautiful rising
up of some of those voices,
kind of like a cross-section
of that community.
And you can read in here how
people are talking together.
There are so many
echoes among the poems.
And I think related to
theme, it's hard, you know,
reading it through so
many times, you're going
to find layers and layers
of themes and conversations
that are happening
among the poems.
And one of those, of course,
does have to do with identity
and how we are multiple,
how we are able to be rooted
and centered in a place or a
people, a community, a Nation,
and at the same time
be multiple.
And I think that's,
that's probably how I would
talk about that, you know?
Also for me it's -- I
went to the Institute
of American Indian
Arts as an undergrad,
and that was really illuminating
to me because I grew up living,
like I said, you know, summers
in Oklahoma and school years
in -- mostly in Europe,
actually.
And so I felt very close
to my heritage, you know,
because I just knew
my relationship
with this country was -- on
one hand it was just kind
of like a -- you know, my
father was in the Embassy,
so it was a very
formalized relationship
to the United States, being
representative of that abroad.
And at the same time,
my relationship
with this country was -- I
knew I was from the land, too,
and I knew the stories.
I thank my mother for telling
me the stories and the history.
So since I was young I
-- we knew, you know,
our family was part
of who we are.
Our family's dialogues,
where we came from.
So my sense of multiplicity
in being --
I wouldn't say being divided,
because I don't feel
like it's a division.
And when I went to the Institute
of American Indian Arts,
it was like -- it was great.
I mean, as a kid, I got to
go to international schools,
and I met people from
all over the world,
the different languages
and cultures and religions.
And then I went to the Institute
of American Indian Arts
and I got to be with people from
different languages and cultures
and ways of being in the world.
And I just think that's
a beautiful thing.
And I think that's
reflected in this book, too.
>> Rob Casper: Yeah.
Could you read a poem
that might reflect that?
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Yeah.
I was thinking when
she was answering
of this poem by Sy Hoahwah.
And Sy is -- he's Comanche
and Southern Arapaho.
He's lived all over Oklahoma.
I'm just reading this
through real quick.
But he is also currently
living in Arkansas.
And I always think
it's interesting
that people don't
think of Native people
in certain parts of the country.
They're like, oh, they
don't have any Natives here
when I visit.
But there he is in Arkansas.
And I think like it helps
to think of this poem
as a graphic novel,
so each section is
like a little cartoon,
so if you can draw it
in your head while I read it.
I'm going to switch glasses.
Sorry. I'm old.
Oops [laughter].
Throwing my glasses around.
These are my grandpa glasses.
"Anchor-Screws of Culture."
After watching the deceased
Comanche Nation princess get
snagged on an anchor
screw as she crawled
out of the mausoleum, the first
groundskeeper retrieved a pair
of hedge-clippers.
But was chased by a swarm of
bees in the shape of a big hand.
Second groundskeeper brandished
his brand new cordless drill.
He just had a birthday.
Third groundskeeper
quickly made the oil
and gasoline mixture
for the weed-eaters.
Fourth groundskeeper
put out his cigarette
on the back of a concrete lamb.
And the fifth groundskeeper
hooked up water hoses,
but stopped to help a
spider loosen its fangs
from an empty grasshopper.
The clouds went by
like a Two-Step dance.
Instantly I fell in love
with the Comanche culture all
over again [laughter].
So to me that kind of
answers that question
of how do you negotiate
things you think about.
And Sy has like lots of vampires
and zombies in his poetries,
very much the contemporary, you
know sensibility of that goth
or post-goth, you know,
post-apocalyptic
kind of worldview.
But also centered on
Comanche culture, so.
>> Rob Casper: Yeah.
Let's talk about the cover.
Since you asked, is
there a way to show it
up on the screens
where you can see it.
This beautiful, beautiful image.
>> Heid E. Erdrich:
Yeah, the image --
>> Rob Casper: Shamenda
Tui [assumed spelling].
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Yeah,
Shamenda Tui who is a Dine poet
who couldn't be in
the collection.
He was working on a new
book-length poem essentially,
and it just -- he didn't
yet feel he could be part
of the collection, or it
could separated it out..
Sherman -- Sherwin was
showing his photographs on,
I don't know, Instagram
or somewhere,
and I really got intrigued
by them, and I said, oh,
I didn't know you
were an artist.
He said, yeah, I paint
and I do photographs.
So eventually when they
asked about a cover,
I suggested this piece of
artwork with his permission.
It was taken in Hawaii
and it was just a piece
of driftwood found on the beach.
And I thought it was really
beautiful and full of hope
and kind of a sense
of uplift, you know,
uplifting of us as people.
It wasn't until we were actually
in production that I found
out that the hand is not
Sherwin's, which I assumed.
It is the hand of Laura
Ortman who you performed with.
She's a concert violinist?
>> Jennifer Elise
Foerster: Yeah.
>> Heid E. Erdrich:
And a composer.
>> Jennifer Elise
Foerster: In Brooklyn.
>> Heid E. Erdrich: And
her Native Nation is?
>> Jennifer Elise
Foerster: Oh, I don't know.
>> Heid E. Erdrich:
I can't remember.
But she's a Native
woman as well.
So I just --
>> Yeah.
>> Heid E. Erdrich: -- you
know, I thought that was just
so perfect that, you know, this
art and music and, you know,
we holistically -- cultures
don't separate those things.
Ojibwe people, we
sing our poems.
You know, we may not
have great voices,
but that doesn't
matter [laughter].
You sing your dreams,
your living poems, your --
you know, that's what you do,
that's what you're supposed
to do, and that's what people
did for, you know, millennia.
And that's true of
many cultures,
so like I love it the --
you know, the separations
are not there.
A lot of the poets are
also visual artists --
>> Rob Casper: Yeah.
>> Heid E. Erdrich: --
musicians, among other things.
>> Rob Casper: Yeah.
I should say that if you'd like
to see Laura Ortman perform,
you can watch the webcast of the
Witter Bynner Fellowship Reading
with Allison Hedge Coke who
brought Laura to the Library
and performed the poem
with her and a whole band.
It was an amazing experience
and it clearly made
true what you're talking
about about this multi
genre approach to poetry.
You talked a little bit
about being surprised
by the poets you
didn't know about.
Can maybe both of you can
talk a little bit more
about what surprised
you in this anthology --
poems, poets, themes, ways
of negotiating, questions.
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Yeah.
I didn't know about Jillian
Telemontes Beraski [assumed
spelling] who uses
the pronoun "itch"
and it has this amazing use of
all types of English language
as well as some of indigenous
language and many of the poets
that I got attracted to use
indigenous language, too,
in their work or -- I shouldn't
say used because it's, you know,
evoked it, expressed
within their own languages.
And that was a part of my
taste in the work was to look
at those poems and
be inclusive of them.
Some are not translated
such as Gwen Westermann's --
one of her Dakota poems.
Some are translated
within the text.
Some are just meant for
an audience of those
who could read the language
and I couldn't read them all.
So -- but to me the -- our
language teachers tell us
that we want to speak
the original languages
of this place, and it's
part of our future.
It's not part of our past.
It's part of our future
and our continuation.
So however you need to do,
whether it's through poetry
or teaching kids, you
know, it doesn't matter.
So that surprised me.
You know, playfulness.
A lot of the people think
of the sadness and the sort
of backward glancing or
nostalgia made of poetry.
And these are playful poems.
These are poems with
serious intent but funny, so.
>> Jennifer Elise
Foerster: Yeah.
I think what I love about it
and that always surprises me --
and the poems are good poems
because they're surprising
every time you read them.
And I think I did
an excellent job
of choosing the poems
nd choreographing a book
because it reveals just
the diversity of poetics,
not just themes, but poetics.
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Mm-hmm.
>> Jennifer Elise Foerster:
You know, we have a range
of poetic modes going on in this
book, from documentary poetics
and different kind
of syntactical play
and narrative work and different
even like typographies and,
you know, using -- some poets
use the page in a very open way
and others are very lyrical with
stanzas and -- I just love that.
It shows a variety
of poetics as well.
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Yeah.
I think I was attracted
to that, too.
Just, you know, getting a sense
of the voice of that poet.
So from their first book --
I include something
from everybody's first
book except for one person.
I just couldn't.
But all the way through
to their most current work
and unpublished works, so.
I'm going to read
one of the poems
from [inaudible] first book.
It's really quick and it's
-- I'm going to try --
Trevino's got a great voice.
It's very deep.
I can't quite do it, but
-- For the Sake of Beauty.
On the phone, I asked her to
wear a full buckskin outfit
and she could be the beauty
that would make me steal horses.
She said, She didn't
have a buckskin outfit.
I said I would make her one,
but use the pages from books.
A week later, when she
came over to my place,
she asked if I'd made an outfit.
I said no.
I couldn't bring
myself to hunt the books
on my shelf [laughter] even if
it were for food or clothing.
I couldn't bring myself
to kill even if it was
for the sake of beauty
[applause].
>> Jennifer Elise
Foerster: Amazing.
>> Rob Casper: That's a
lovely poem [inaudible].
>> Heid E. Erdrich:
That's Trevino --
[ Applause ]
But, yeah.
I mean I was surprised by many
things and attracted to things
that were different, you know.
Had I done the book in year two
if I'd finished the manuscript,
it would have been very
different from what I was able
to finish in 2017 because my
taste broadened, my ability,
my understanding of poets,
especially GLBTQ plus two
spirit poets really changed
and I was more appreciative
of the works.
And found them because they'd
been marginalized, too, so.
>> Rob Casper: It's interesting
that you bring that up.
What I meant, publishing
this anthology now.
And, of course, you're
not only an editor,
you're a great poet yourself.
I'm interested in how
the two of you felt --
how you felt about having --
doing this anthology
now for you as a poet.
And, Jennifer, I'm interested in
what this anthology meant coming
up now for you as opposed to,
say, when you were working
on your first book or first
discovering the great wealth
and new writers around
the country.
>> Jennifer Elise Foerster:
Well, I'm glad it came
out when it did [laughter].
I think because some of
the poets in this book,
their first book
did just come out.
Tacey, right?
Her first book --
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Tacey, 2018.
>> Jennifer Elise Foerster: --
her first book Rain
Scald just came out.
And so it allowed those
voices to be in it, too.
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Mm-hmm.
>> Jennifer Elise Foerster:
I was grateful for that.
>> Heid E. Erdrich: And then --
I mean, these poets
have been writing
for 10/15 years most of them.
They just couldn't
get published.
Tommy Pico now has three books,
boom-boom-boom, right in a row,
and he -- and winning
national awards.
But he could not get published.
I think [inaudible] that -- I
think he sent it out 27 times,
which is a lot of work.
Sending a book of
poetry out takes a --
you have to wait
for it to come back,
you have to produced
the manuscript,
you have to fill
out an author form.
You have to do so much to
get those books out there,
and you know, with no hope
of getting any money
out of the deal.
>> Jennifer Elise
Foerster: No [laughter].
>> Heid E. Erdrich: So,
you know, it's something,
it's a contest, et cetera.
So these poets were
out there struggling
to be heard, a lot of them.
And I was just grateful
that they shared their
first successes with me.
I was really grateful for that
because they didn't have to.
A lot of them didn't know me.
They weren't maybe even hooked
in with the Native
Writing Community until --
which is still forming.
It really has grown a lot
in the past 10 years, so --
I don't think we're
a school of poetry
because our poetics
are not prescribed,
but we are a community, an
intimate community as he said
for better or for worse.
>> Jennifer Elise
Foerster: Yeah.
>> Rob Casper: There is that
larger question, though,
of what's happened in
the even five years.
It's interesting to
see in the September,
2018 issue of The Atlantic .
They had a big article by
Jesse Lichtenstein called
"How Poetry Came to Matter
Again," which is a play off
of Dana Gioia's "Can
Poetry Matter" article
that was so foundational.
And he talks about all sorts
of poets including
Layli Long Soldier.
But it was very exciting to
feel that after many years
of seeing articles about the
death of poetry, about poetry
as elitist, and not
connected to the lives
of "ordinary Americans,"
quote/unquote, to see a kind
of sea change in the
major media and at
that same time there's
an explosion of all sorts
of exciting young poets from all
sorts of parts of the country
who are, I think, expanding our
sense of what poetry can mean.
But why do you think
suddenly there are a bunch
of exciting new poets or
poets who have been writing
and something, as you
say with Tom Pico,
boom-boom-boom, three
books in a row?
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Mm-hmm.
Well I think the -- just
the diversity of the --
or our country, of America,
of the U.S., and the diversity
and growth of Native Nations is
allowing for that possibility.
And I think people are
interested in hearing voices
that are not their own.
And there's more of an openness
to that, especially in poetry.
The audience is much
younger and we now know
from the NEA study
the performed work
of poetry has come
back into play.
And for Native poets, I think
that has always been a thing,
the idea of performance
of poetry,
although it's perfectly fine
to have somebody
who doesn't perform.
It's a little harder, but
I perform my work more
than I publish it in
journals or magazines
because I want a relationship
with the people I'm
performing to and with.
I want to have that
moment of human connection.
So I think part of it is that.
But probably the main
thing is just social media
and the Internet.
You could get a following.
You could get some way to --
if I couldn't just throw an
email off to Jeff Shotts,
this never would have happened
because I wouldn't have dared
to go like knock on the door
and make an appointment and talk
to Jeff who is the greatest,
sweetest, most humble person
in the world who's made a huge
impact on American poetry.
Yeah.
>> Jennifer Elise Foerster:
Yeah, I agree with all that.
And I think that what's happened
in the last some years is --
you now, we're living
in the place --
time of pretty numbing rhetoric.
And poetry is a language
like none other.
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Hi, Natalie.
>> Jennifer Elise Foerster: It's
a language of the imagination
and it's a language that opens
the apertures of insight.
And we need that.
and with that, we're so glad
that Natalie Diaz is here.
>> Heid E. Erdrich:
Natalie Diaz arrived, yeah.
[ Applause ]
>> Natalie Diaz:
[Inaudible] that's also late
apparently [laughter].
Better late than never as
my grandmother would say.
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Yes.
Well we have -- we're
at our 15-minute mark.
I'll let you catch your breath.
Should we do questions for a
minute until Natalie is ready
to read or should we --
>> Rob Casper: How do
you want to jump in?
>> Natalie Diaz: Whatever.
At this point I'm not sure
[laughter] whatever it is we
want to do.
>> Rob Casper: Let's
have you jump in, yeah.
Thank you for, thank
you for getting here.
Poor Natalie had a
mysterious plane issues.
She arrived at past midnight
last night into Washington, D.C.
>> Natalie Diaz: Yeah.
That's [inaudible].
I mean, I'm here, which
is lucky [inaudible].
>> Rob Casper: Well,
we're thrilled
to have her, and here you go.
>> Natalie Diaz:
Just [inaudible].
>> Rob Casper: You
want some water?
>> Natalie Diaz: I'm glad
Heid and Jennifer love me.
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Oh, yeah.
>> Natalie Diaz: And
I hope some of you --
>> Heid E. Erdrich: I
love you for getting here.
>> Rob Casper: Come on.
>> Natalie Diaz: Thank you.
>> Heid E. Erdrich:
Yeah, you're --
[ Applause ]
>> Rob Casper: Since we're
thinking about the importance
of this new anthology,
it's great to have a
dramatic entrance [laughter].
>> Natalie Diaz: Yeah.
>> Yeah [inaudible].
>> Natalie Diaz: Well, had
a dramatic history, so --
>> Heid E. Erdrich: I don't
think your microphone's quite
working out.
But I just want to say, just
in introducing Natalie while she
catches her breath and drinks,
that one of the poems that I
love in this collection is sort
of an essay in American
arithmetic by Natalie Diaz.
And I -- like I said, I
have a critical taste.
I have a taste for the critical,
the reading within poetry,
the conversation, the dialog.
It's really just my style.
There's many, many
other styles of writing.
But I so appreciate
that poem in particular.
I don't know if you
want to read it or not.
And --
>> Natalie Diaz: Yeah, yeah.
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Yeah,
though would be great.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
>> Natalie Diaz: Good
morning [foreign words].
American Arithmetic.
Native Americans make up less
than 1% of the population
of America, .8% of 100%.
Oh, mine efficient country.
I do not remember the
days before America --
I do not remember the days
when we were all here.
Police kill Native Americans
more than any other race.
Race is a funny word.
Race implies someone will win,
implies I have as good a chance
of winning as -- who wins
the race which isn't a race?
Native Americans make up
1.9% of all police killings,
higher than any race, and we
exist as .8% of all Americans.
Sometimes race means run.
We are not good at math.
Can you blame us?
We've had an American education.
We are Americans and we are
less than 1% of Americans.
We do a better job of dying
by police than we do existing.
When we are dying,
who should we call?
The police?
Or our senator?
Please, someone, call my mother.
In Arithmetic and in America,
divisibility has rules --
divide without remainder.
At the National Museum
of the American Indian,
68% of the collection is
from the United States.
I am doing my best to not
become a museum of myself.
I am doing my best to
breathe in and out.
I am begging -- let me be
lonely but not invisible.
But in this American
city with all its people,
I am Native American, less
than one, less than whole.
I am less than myself.
Only a fraction of a body.
Let's say, I am only a hand, and
when I slip it beneath the shirt
of my lover I disappear
completely.
[ Applause ]
>> Rob Casper: That's
such a wonderful poem
because it shows how poems
can both contain what we seek
in prose, which is the
statistical analysis,
and total subvert
it and explode it
with a kind of lyrical
intensity.
So, thank you so much
for reading that.
Do you want to read another one?
You up for it?
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Yes.
[ Applause ]
>> Jennifer Elise
Foerster: Please do.
>> Natalie Diaz: Yeah.
Don't forget, you don't
have to feel poor for me.
This happens to people
in much worse ways.
My trip here was so much easier
than people's trip trying
to cross the border
right now, to --
>> Heid E. Erdrich:
Yeah, exactly.
>> Natalie Diaz: --
to save their lives,
so this is quite lucky.
[ Applause ]
>> Natalie Diaz: This
one kind of goes fast,
so I'm hoping I have enough
hydration in me for it.
This actually began
with a line --
I was reading Orlando
Wright's book, Bone Right .
That's a book that's
made a big impact on me,
and you'll hear a line in
here that says Orlando Zero.
And I was thinking about that
little white skull of space
that he images so
powerfully in his book.
So you'll hear that
little section.
Dome Riddle.
Tonight I am riddled
by this sick soul,
this right bowling ball zipped
in the sad sack carrying case
of my face, this over-round
bone Jack-in-the-box,
this Orlando's zero --
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
This sticky, sweet guilt type.
This small town mania
dispensary,
prescribed cranium pill,
this electric blue tom-tom
drum ticking like an acne bomb,
hypnotized explosive device,
pensive general scalp
strapped worrier,
soldier with a loaded
god complex,
this Hotchkiss obliterated
headdress,
Gatling-lit labyrinth,
this memory grenade,
and death epithet, death
epitaph, mound of momento mori,
this 22-part talisman
wearing a skirt of brass,
giant ball of masa, this
god patella in the long leg
of my torso, zoo of
canines and Blake's tigers,
this red-skinned apple,
lamp illuminated by teeth,
gang of grins, spitwad of
scheme, this jawbone of an ass,
smiling sliver of smite, David's
rock striking the Goliath
of my body, this library of
Babel, homegrown Golgotha,
nostalgia menagerie,
melon festival,
this language mausoleum --
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
-- this hidden glacier hungry
for a taste of titanic flesh,
this pleasure alter,
French-kiss sweatshop,
abacus of one night stands,
hippocampus whorehouse,
oubliette of regret, this church
of tongue, chapel of vengeance,
cathedral of thought,
bone dome of despair --
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
-- this museum of
tribal dentistry,
commodity cranium cupboard,
petrified dreamcatcher,
this sun-ruined basketball
I haul,
rabid gray along the seams,
perpetual missed shot,
this insomnia podium, little
bowl in a big fish, brain,
amphitheater, girl in the moon,
this 3 a.m. war bell
doing day vision prison,
this single scoop vanilla
headrush, thunderhead, fastball,
lightening rod, this mad
scientist in a white lab helmet,
ghost of smoking mirror, this
coyote beacon, calcium corral
of pale palomino ponies, this
desert seed I am root to,
night-blooming [inaudible]
rattle,
this Halloween crown hat-rack
worry contraption, rainbows,
drunken boat, blazing
chandelier,
casa [foreign words],
this coliseum [inaudible],
bore his other tiger
licking the empty shell
of locus white Tortuga,
this underdressed god head
forever hatching egg, this mug,
again and again at my lips.
And all this because tonight
I imagined you sleeping
with her the way we once slept,
as intimate as a jaw, maxilla
and mandible hot in the skin, in
love, our heads almost touching.
>> Beautiful.
[ Applause ]
>> Could I just say
that my collaborator
in reading that was incredible.
That's like --
[ Applause ]
>> Natalie Diaz: Like I
[inaudible] get such a gift
that we get to see poetry
as physical as it is.
Sometimes we forget
it's physical,
we forget it's about the body.
We get stuck on this like eye to
ear thing that we do with text,
but that was like sometimes --
this to me is like the highlight
of anything I could have read,
was watching language in motion.
So, gracias.
[ Applause ]
>> Rob Casper: And so I'd
love to give you a chance
to ask any questions
you'd like to ask.
There are mics on either side.
Please come up.
We have about 10 minutes.
Of course I could talk
all day with these three,
but I'm sure you have
questions to ask.
>> Heid E. Erdrich: And
we have a sign-in --
>> Rob Casper: We
have a sign-in, yes.
>> Heid E. Erdrich:
Yeah, it's 12:30 I think.
Is that right?
1:00? 1:30.
So if you want to --
>> Rob Casper: So
the mics are --
yeah, the mics are
over on either side.
>> Natalie Diaz: [Inaudible]
is at 12:30 [laughter].
>> Heid E. Erdrich:
Great at that.
>> Rob Casper: So, go ahead.
>> My question is for the
editor of the anthology.
Did you have difficulties in --
did you have difficulties
in selecting the poets?
What was your criteria for --
how did you decide that these
words are going to be in
and did you have a sort
of timeline or are you --
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Yeah.
>> -- looking at the
criteria of their work?
>> Heid E. Erdrich: Well,
first they had to be poets
who engaged me in general,
beyond the list that,
and that I felt that
had an audience.
That was important to me,
too, that there were folks
who were reading these poets
and were interested in them.
It wasn't about the
age of the poets.
It was about when they
published their first book
from the year 2000
forward, and, in general,
I make decisions very quickly.
I knew what I wanted
and I just chose --
and luckily I was allowed to
just choose out of my own taste
and my own sense of
how the whole was going
to come together.
I did require that people
have some specific connection
to a Native Nation however.
That was one of my -- I'm
not about blood [inaudible]
or descendancy or race
or anything about that.
And I also wanted people
from different directions
of geography in the country
so that I got a sense
of the land, you know.
Physically people who live and
have relatives on the borders
of the U.S. as well as folks
from all over, and Guam
and Hawaii and Alaska,
to make sure
that we understand ourselves
as part of Native Nations
that are connected under
this political entity
of the U.S. It's really
important to me because I think
that more and more we will face
challenges to our Nationhood,
and I want us to have bodies of
expression that can meet that
and to teach the American
public that we persist
as Nations regardless of who's
going to come for our resources
or our physical bodies.
[ Applause ]
>> Hi. There's a lot
of talk these days
about cultural appropriation,
but I'm sure
that you also want many people
to read this anthology
far beyond, you know,
from all cultures,
nationalities,
and that you want those
people, if they're writers,
to be influenced by the
writers in the book.
So I was wondering if you
could talk a little bit
about being influenced by
writers of other nationalities
or other cultures
besides your own,
and cultural appropriation
on the other hand.
>> Jennifer Elise Foerster:
I got just my first thought,
I'll just speak to that,
is that when I'm influenced
by other writers,
influenced poetically,
then it's because I'm
engaged with their poetics.
And that may or may not -- of
course, one's poetics is always
about who they are,
which includes culture
and all of that.
But I think the richness
of poetry in the world is
that we can be influenced by
one another in our poetics
and that love of each other's
poetics, whether it's --
we're resonant with it
or we have differences
with it is another way that we
can be a conversation and be
in conversation as humans
with our differences.
And so I don't think that
it has to do necessarily --
it doesn't have to do with
appropriation to be, to listen,
and listening is part
of that influence.
>> Heid E. Erdrich:
One of the things
that I did a little differently
with the anthology was to have
in the biography people
answer certain questions
in the author bio, so they talk
about who their influences are
in those bios or they talk
about who mentored them
so you can see the connections.
Mostly Native writers
mentoring one another,
even some of the people in the
book mentoring one another.
But also, you know, the poets
that are meaningful to them,
so you see that sort of
generational influence I think.
>> Natalie Diaz:
And appropriation --
we always forget this, like
appropriation has a lot to do
with the fact that
you're erasing the people
who you have taken from.
You know, like America
loves to wear a headdress
and they would much rather --
I mean, they do nothing
to take care of Natives
or to give them a place to --
you know, we couldn't
even practice our religion
until 1978, yeah, you know,
like some of us weren't
even born then.
And so I think that's
something, too, is like --
and always to ask
yourself why, like why,
why is this necessary to write?
Like I think in the book
you can see the necessity,
like these things had to be
written for these writers.
And so I think that's
something to consider, too,
with influences like when you
find something that, you know --
it has -- so we always use
that word like, I like this.
But, really, it's because
it showed you something
of your life or it showed you
something of your own world.
And you don't have to be Native
to see our world we're
all living in in this book
or the pains that we sometimes
suffer, you know, even if it's
across culture or across Nation.
And so I think that's
something important, too,
is that appropriation is
not just the influence
or engaging in a conversation.
But it's also like the
obliteration or erasure
of the person who that came
from, whose work that came from.
So I think that's an important
thing to jump into the equation.
>> Rob Casper: Okay.
>> Heid E. Erdrich:
We're at time.
>> Rob Casper: We're at time.
One more quick question.
Your one quick question.
>> Well, I just heard you talk
around about having
the discussion
within the poetry community
and that a lot of the poems
in the book are sort of a
discussion back and forth.
And I'm wondering
what the mechanics
of that discussion are.
Is this when you get
together in person?
Are you communicating
through email?
You know, how is this
discussion going on
and how are you helping
each other?
>> Heid E. Erdrich: I'm going
to say the simplest answer,
yes and no [laughter].
And I'm so sorry.
I have to happily talk to you
about what I mean by that.
It's more of a poetics
than it is an actual thing.
But I wanted to say in the
Nishnabe we say [foreign words]
which means thank you
for listening to me.
That's about enough.
[ Applause ]
>> Rob Casper: Thanks
all for coming.
Thanks all for coming.
The booksigning should be on --
I think its at 12:30/1 o'clock.
It should be on your app, the
National Book Festival app.
Hope to see you soon.
>> Jennifer Elise
Foerster: Thank you.